oh there my name is Paul Walters this is
my wife Anne and this is the life of a
property investor
[Music]
we're in the midst at the moment of
refinancing a property that we've got up
in Oldham we are also selling the
property we've got down in East Sussex
to release the equity that we've got
tied up in that just to basically
basically what we need we want our cash
flow to increase our cash flow each
month so we're going to be investing
further up north three more properties
up north hopefully this year and another
one beyond self but the down south one
purely be a sort of a fixer-upper we'll
flip that yeah we do that out flip it
then once again invest the money back
there and self again for another one and
take it from there and just just just
keep rolling them on as and when they
come in just just keep good doing it
it's also in the crash course and we
learned about that leasing that so some
councils will release properties off you
and that's what you know we went didn't
mean phone up the council's yes council
you know that's really strange because
like we've just got the go-ahead from
the government to start leasing
properties of people so you couldn't
believe we'd phoned so soon after they'd
heard this news and they went two weeks
later when we actually finished it then
we signed a lease agreement for three
years must have been the next day I
think after signing there a fat got a
family to move in and they've been here
the last three years and the counts were
paid it's like every week it's just gone
on it's just guaranteed rent there's no
voids as if there was a void then the
council still pay you so and they were
just about to do another three-year
contract but we were hoping to sell that
to an investor I didn't want to sell
that house because I do love it but you
know talking to Paul and you know you
were saying well we get about nine
hundred pounds a month off of the
council in rent on that one but with the
money from that we can buy two or three
properties up north and where we can get
like five hundred pounds each property
so if we've got you know three houses up
there then we get be getting a lot more
rent so all it all made sense there
yes that that is definitely the way to
go
[Music]
where we are at our property in Hastings
we're just about to go and have a little
look around do some filming in that it's
a property that we're just about to put
on the market
[Music]
why do we buy it basically has an
investment like you who lived here when
we bought it she split up with her
partner and they had basically had to
sell it so that's the reason why we
bought it he was beside me was a
three-day can property we've ended off
conversion putting there to convert it
to a four-bedroom don't quite a lot of
work on it because it wasn't yeah yeah I
mean it was liveable my lady lived there
and everything but it was a little bit
tight a little bit tight inside it'll
work - it will always have a small
garden it was LMS lady before I said
quite a big dog
yeah there's a lot of Mythology a lot of
thinking that we don't man but yeah
that's the other side yeah a manageable
deal
the last time they lived here she found
us up because I summon reached night
waking everything room so they asked if
they could do it off cumbersome or he
could do it off conversion for them
which we did but they're the tenant wing
that when the building chap come round
to check everything
the venn tenant kept asking for this
wall here just to be pushed across
penalties so she'd get boards I've been
there and as much as we was trying to
tell you it couldn't be done she said
that she spoke to the man from the
council and he said it's an easy job it
might be a stud wall and it might be
easy but you can't just push it because
he's got two door frames connected to it
who's got the lighting it's got the soft
sort of everything and it took a little
bit of negotiations before the penny
finally dropped that you can't just push
away about things back like that
unfortunately but entertaining nice
when we came up here when we thought
when we didn't realize when we bought
the house that the fact that all days
not the plaster work but all the were
all just standing although all the
woodwork had already been put in these
frameworks for the big upswing ders was
already in apparently when the houses
were built the Builder run out of money
because I think I was always intended to
have this is a second floor but so the
joist were already to be clicked joy so
he didn't put any steals in we didn't
have to put any new joist or anything
game we literally had to plaster board
it put a staircase in and put a couple
of windows in and that was really it for
the loft conversion once the lofts took
not conversions being done once again
you've got fire doors on there
everything needs to be sort of 30 30
minutes protection so if there's a fire
in here it can't get out and down them
down the stairwell and at the bottom the
stairs did you stop go straight into the
lounge so obviously if there was a fire
in the lounge then the fire could go
straight up the stairs so hence we had
to put partition the lounge off from the
hallway and put a fire door man the
ceilings below this there were ways like
I say they've had to be over boarded and
skimmed over so if there's a fire
downstairs it can't get up through the
ceiling to this floor it gives you
another half an hour so I think it's
obviously once you've got up to this
floor the second floor up it could be
problem if the figures on this property
we we paid one hundred and thirty four
thousand five hundred for the equity so
two seven years ago we spent about
twenty four thousand doing the loft
conversion and all the fire legs and
everything we refinance the property
three years ago three years ago we
pulled out sixty thousand pounds which
was our money and more that we put into
the property but it seems obviously it's
down in the southeast and you get a lot
of capital growth and now we've got
there's a hundred thousand pounds worth
of equity sitting in this property which
we'd like to have seen in our bank so he
decided to sell the property now
I won't be sittin in a bank for long no
no no guys hey will we be going up north
with a lot we want to buy another
property within an hour's drive of where
we live and that we would do that up
ourselves like we did this one up and
then sell that and then with the rest of
money want to buy at least two possibly
three up that north to do up refurb
refinance and then they've been getting
them rented out basically something off
every turn I mean but yeah so I don't
know what we have in common
yeah there's capital growth still AM so
obviously we like we like a mix of both
we like portfolio up in the water
yeah I'm capital capital for investment
for a point of view from the money
coming into the bank account and damn
self the ROI the return on investment is
not fantastic to ourselves but you do
get good capital growth so it's nice to
have a little mixed you about
[Music]
with just two important
the Middle Ages it's where the outlet is
I mean days just now the only one who
produced identities that is to blame at
the flag
[Music]
and that silly little mean - they're
going to a hundred patiently we've just
been in there having a cup of coffee
I've got a phone call from a HMA letting
agent up and downs gruff they've got to
do that I've new job okay so we've just
been going over some figures and to see
whether it's a viable preposition to pay
for my fingers crossed on that one
you